gusta al sádr era poco conocido fuera de
irak antes de la invasión liderada por
estados unidos en 2003 desde la
ocupación se convirtió en un símbolo de
resistencia aprovechando el legado de su
familia
sadam husein mandó asesinar a su padre
el gran ayatolá mohamed sadeq al sádr en
con su ejército metí al sádr lideró dos
revueltas contra eeuu y era buscado vivo
o muerto por washington a lo largo de
los años sus seguidores también han
luchado contra el ejército iraquí
durante la guerra civil sectaria de 2006
a 2008 contra los militantes del estado
islámico y contra las milicias chiitas
rivales tras sufrir una importante
derrota en basora en 2008 al sádr ordenó
el cese de las operaciones armadas
entonces ingresó al mundo político y su
popularidad fue en creyendo debido a sus
promesas de acabar con la corrupción
estatal se autoproclama nacionalista
chiíta se opone a toda influencia
estadounidense así como iraní en irak o
libia irak pertenece sólo a los iraquíes
todas las armas deben estar en manos del
estado aragua en 2016 al sádr lideró el
primer levantamiento antigubernamental
en la joven democracia iraquí cuando sus
partidarios asaltaron el parlamento en
2018 formó una alianza con comunistas y
laicistas obteniendo buenos resultados
en las elecciones parlamentarias desde
entonces su movimiento sadrista ha
pasado a dominar la política iraquí
quedando en primer lugar en las
elecciones parlamentarias de 2020 a
pesar de su influencia en 2022 al sádr
no logró poner fin a un prolongado
estancamiento para formar gobierno
he decidido retirarme el proceso
político para no participar de ninguna
manera con los corruptos de cama al
fácil y
el saber de un paso más allá este agosto
anunciando el cierre de las oficinas de
su movimiento
[Música]